when I first came back in January for
the Royal Rumble it had been seven years
at birth to children and I was like I
actually didn't know I could do it you
know and when they said to me like you
know will you be a part of this I just
said um listen I'm gonna talk with my
family mm-hmm I'll get back to you and
really I just forgot my family had to
call my ring guy and I was like dude you
got to get a ring set up because I gotta
see if I give you this time so I went in
there and I just I hit my trademark
moves I'm like okay and it's so crazy
like I've discovered that wrestling is
like learn is like riding a bike right
once you do it your body just kind of
knows Spanish goes after Natalia and out
Bailey and Oscar as well and our Sasha
banks hey Trish Stratus taking it to
everybody in the meantime I got into
great shape it just happened you know
you're you're busting your butt like
every single day and so we took the
opportunity couple magazines approached
me they're excited about this you know I
kept saying I'm like Emma I'm a mom
who's gonna go in the ring with these
like 20-something girls and I'm gonna
kill it I mean hopefully that's the plan
and then when I did it it was like that
was it was so empowering to be able to
do that to know that like you know you
can do that to have the confidence in
your body and because you know there's
moments you're like I've had kids I'm
just a mom I'm not I don't do that
anymore
so then you know it was a real
confidence booster so Trish what's the
training been like getting ready for
evolution it's been insane I have to say
cuz you know um back in the day I
literally would just my job was to be a
wrestler so I'd get up and I'd wrestle
and I would train an Evo wrestle that
was really it hmm and now I have two
babies as a household I have for another
business and so then I gotta find which
I had my regular yoga training mmm which
isn't gonna cut it you know which I'm
thankful for cuz at least when they call
me after like seven years of being in
the ring they're like are you ready to
do this like I think so I'm trial enough
and so now we've been putting in
strength training and then what I do to
put the kids to bed and I do ring
training as well so very little sleep
yeah what are the kids think about you
getting back in the ring it's so funny
whenever I put on this ring here the
whole fame ring yeah he's like Oh mommy
you're going to work he this is like my
superhero ring like so yeah so he knows
works happening good stuff and I
actually showed us on my training videos
for another day been training up in the
ring in school so he saw them and he was
like whoa and then the other day he said
I'm gonna wrestle II when he just like
lay down on me know like all of it like
first it'll like peek over see you're
getting in the ring partnering with Lita
going against Mickie James
Alexa bliss you all have a lot of
experience we miss you all are
exceptional at it when do you know when
you're putting them s together that is
just clicking that it's working you know
when you're doing it live for the crowd
in the reacting you probably need a
little practice I think they're right we
do need some practice tough some
practice right now the great thing is
fueled by storylines people are excited
about the heat between us so when we get
in it's just to be like that Rumble
between us we will be making history in
the first-ever all-women's pay-per-view
w2b evolution when I first started one
of the things that I set out to do was
to change the perception of women in
this industry and you know obviously as
you know back in the day we weren't a
mate we weren't main players we were
accessories we're on the side we have
you're the eye candy and things like
that and so I worked really hard we
managed to have many many like
opportunities that allowed us to then
showcase the women in different way show
them as an athletic woman and show them
that like the women could hang just like
this boys
[Music]